in this third section of the newsreel
record of our invasion
these further graphic pictures show the
consolidation of the beachhead positions
and the thrust in land the weather was
none too good
but the little ships plugged on manfred
to the beaches bringing enormous support
in manpower and weapons
and bringing also the mechanical needs
of our army and air force
the means to build our first airfields
in france since 1940.
after a day when the skies were too grey
for useful flying the great air forces
went once more into the attack
in strength again the air vibrated with
a roar of hundreds of bombers and
fighters airfields communications and
enemy troops were strapped and blasted
every bridge over the scene between
paris and the coast was wrecked
this was air power on a scale to dwarf
even the grandeur of nazi dreams
[Music]
[Music]
and all the time the sea and beaches
were alive with the activity of
anglo-american invasion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wider and wider grew the scene the
beachhead grew in depth and width
from the beaches spearheads struck out
and pressed in land
through the villages towards car east
senior and karen town and mont bergens
and mary glees in the north towards
sherborough
fighting over open country and in the
streets destroying the german conquerors
of france
capturing their supply dumps and taking
prisoners airborne units fought an
engagement here close to the gliders in
which they had landed
and here out of action come german
soldiers in surrender
the first rich fruits of victory for the
united nations
[Music]
and from each village recaptured from
hitler come the people of france
[Music]
whoops
[Music]
[Music]
on board a mine layer soon after the
invasion started supreme commander
eisenhower was watching progress with
admiral ramsey
[Music]
and that other familiar figure whose
name has spelt victory more than once
[Music]
after four years the commander of the
allied field forces stands on the soil
of france
general montgomery has said he didn't
see any atlantic wall
but he did see a wonderfully efficient
system of concrete and steel defense
posts
the skill and courage of our fighting
men overcame them
tough though they were
[Music]
at one point the camera found a german
defender digging himself out of sand in
which he had been buried by a shell
burst
we have learned well the lessons of the
past in a matter of hours the bulldozers
were at work
building landing strips to enable our
warplanes once again to take off and
land in france itself
and now the reinforcements of men and
armor came into the towns
the normandy names have become famous in
a week because of their battles on the
road to berlin
[Music]
from all sectors prisoners were coming
by hundreds growing into thousands
taken out to the ships bound for britain
[Music]
already those airstrips were being used
to evacuate wounded
nurses have been over to the beach head
they picked flowers in the fields of
normandy
while they were waiting for the patients
with whom they flew back to britain
over in britain also the prisoners are
arriving
the men who expected to march in triumph
through the streets of our london
now they come instead in captivity
churchill told them four years ago
that we would fight on the beaches it
turns out to be
their beaches
you